okay so i know i've been mia for a while
kylie jenner is back on instagram and
her four-year-old daughter stormi wants
in on the action stormy wants to be in
this on thursday the makeup mogul
updated fans about the latest lip
product from kylie cosmetics on her
insta story and in a relatable yet
adorable mom life moment her little girl
totally crashed the shot
okay so i know i've been mia for a while
stormy wants to be in this
but i launched a new lip product
lip blackers
get out of here
let me do this for two seconds okay
yeah it took a couple of takes for kylie
to get through her message
let me do this for two seconds
thank you
um so i launched a new lip product
they're called lip lacquers and i
haven't been doing my makeup so i
haven't been able to show you guys but
now
i am
you know getting back to doing my makeup
and i wanted to show you guys
is anyone else getting major kim
kardashian northwest throwback vibes can
i wash my hands can you do it in the
other room i'm in the middle of
something i don't want to get this all
wet sweetie
you remember when kylie's big sis was
attempting to work from home while
quarantining back in 2020
i'm hiding in the guest room you guys
i'm hiding in the guest room because my
kids
will not leave me alone
hey that's me
[Applause]
yeah this let me do this for two seconds
okay it feels like that
north can i please just do my little
tutorial i i it's all i want to do is
one little fun thing for myself
anyway
the insta story marks the 24 year old
reality star's first video since she and
travis welcomed their second child
together last month a son named wolf
stormy excited to be a big sister she is
very excited to be a big sister
kylie announced the arrival of their
little bundle of joy on instagram with
this sweet black and white snap that's
stormy's tiny hand holding onto her baby
brother i love it kylie's rep later
confirmed to e.t that she gave birth
just one day after stormy's fourth
birthday
and when it comes to wolf's unique name
the couple chose travis's real first
name jacques for their little one's
middle name it's so much fun the family
grows and and it's getting bigger all
the time and yeah it's really fun to see
the babies have babies
shortly after his birth a source told et
that kylie and travis are over the moon
adding that they both felt so ready for
this they have wanted to grow their
family and give stormy a sibling for a
while and they couldn't be happier
[Music]
you